[Music]
in january 2022 bloomberg reported that
the federal trade commission is
investigating meta for supposedly
anti-competitive conduct concerning
meta's oculus headset and app store if
true
this is another example of antitrust
overreach
virtual reality and the metaverse are in
their developmental stages markets are
still sorting out what services and
technologies customers will want
yet amazingly the investigators
apparently believe that they know what
prices should be and how devices and
services should be sold
such overreach can severely hamper the
metaverse's growth and development
one concern is about oculus's relatively
low price this is misguided
sony's headset is about the same price
even if the oculus price is below cost
this is common in the gaming industry
where companies subsidize consoles to
get customers into the ecosystem
the regulators should put their
investigative resources elsewhere and
let customers drive the metaverse
what do you think
is meta-damaging competition in the
metaverse
let us know in our poll
and let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe to
more research and videos from aei